[Music]
my name is Gobind I am a product manager
at Google I work on cloud networking and
GK eat networking with me I have my
colleague ray Colleen he's in the back
getting suited up I'll just introduce
ray Colleen is a senior engineer at
Google software engineer at Google he
thinks a lot about policy management and
and multi cluster stuff and you'll see
some of that awesome stuff that that Hey
- team have worked on today the goal of
this presentation here is to to really
give you an idea of three things really
like how to think about security in a
multi cluster world that's one second
you also want to think about how you can
do high-resolution policy management
using kubernetes and sto which are at
the heart of anthos which you've heard a
bunch this week and third finally you'll
understand how to manage this across all
your clusters without having to scale
your security budget so you can scale
your security posture without having to
really spend too much money on it so
that's where we're going with this and
since it's a Thursday afternoon we
understand that it's it's time to leave
soon so we'll try to keep it short and
sweet and hopefully give you the most
entertaining session that we can because
it's security right who doesn't want to
listen to security on a Thursday
afternoon all right just a quick plug
for a dory if you have questions please
you know feel free to use our Dory app
it's it's how we do QA internally at
Google that works really well
we love it so give it a shot if you have
questions we'll be happy to get answers
to you before or after the session
they'll save those questions so we'll be
sure to get oh an sir there's mics so
you can come up there you've already
seen the slide but uh just just this is
actually more for me than it is for you
I've practiced this presentation with
CSB and then they change the name to
anthos like two days before that so so
now if I say CSB I mean anthos so yeah
it's a it's all hand tools now okay
we've got the housekeeping done so let's
get into the content so the agenda for
today will figure out how anthos
puts a framework around network security
and how we think about what security
means in the multi cluster world and and
how defense and death really applies to
that concept which is uh which is how
we've figured out that security should
work in the future we'll see how the
different layers of anthos or kubernetes
and sto specifically give you very high
resolution policy management which you
can use to protect your clusters at
every layer of the system we'll see a
demo where ray will step on up and he'll
show you how to do this very effectively
and very quickly you'll probably never
go back to using stuff that you're using
today so I love it personal advice sorry
and and then we'll talk about anti
security monitoring which is really
important because once you've deployed
your policies you also want to see them
working so we'll talk about how to do
that and then we'll have some closing
thoughts cool let's start with anthos
core values so I don't know if you've
seen these before already but I just
want to level set here modernizing in
places is a keep pillar for for anthos
what we're trying to do is for you to be
able to take advantage of latest cloud
tech without having to leave the comfort
of your home home in this case being on
friend right you don't have to move to
GCP or whatever to to you know take
advantage of all the great tech like you
know gke and other things like we're
working on so you can try this on you on
your own premises and at your own
comfort level and try to migrate over if
that makes sense for you at your own
pace that's the whole value proposition
of anthos another thing we really care
about is automating policy at scale and
why do we do that we've all owned our
own multiple smart devices and they all
fall out of sync and we all we've all
seen that it's it's a huge problem and
you can imagine if you start having
multiple kubernetes clusters or GK
clusters all across the planet let's say
if they start falling out of sync that's
that's not a pleasant thought for anyone
in especially in security so and we want
to take that grunt work out of the
system for you and we want to do it for
you and that's that's where we'll go
with this as well we'll show you how
that's done and ultimately we want to
take all this towards a consistent
experience
that's what's really we're doing here we
want to build this consistent system so
that you only have to build your tech
once and then you can deploy it anywhere
that's really important to us and an
automation is a huge part of that
because it'll help you be consistent
because obviously you don't have time to
keep learning all the new tech as it
comes out you have other things to do as
well so so we want to make sure that you
get a consistent experience using anthos
okay just a quick 10,000 foot view of
what anthos looks like at the top you
know sort of surface a couple of key
things here I know there's a there's a
few things going on so I'll just quickly
go over them anthos control plane is is
really your management plane where you
can do things like policy management
service management and cluster
management and the idea is that for you
to be able to run on Prem or in cloud
GCP or AWS or whatever it is you can run
there but you've only built this once
and you can manage at all centrally from
a single pane of glass and then the
other most more important thing which is
more relevant to this session is
thinking about security from the ground
up so when gke and sto came up you know
as projects security was a core design
principle for all of these technologies
at every step of the way so it has
they've it's a first-class citizen for
for security to be part of these layers
and that's what we really want to talk
about in the in the next few slides in
this in this session ok quick
description of why the slide is here so
we all have been doing security for a
long time and and it's it's it doesn't
we've been doing it for a very long time
ever since we started putting computers
on the internet but it's it's still a
really hard problem and the problem is
the as our security techniques of all
attacks evolve and then we're like ok
it's a chicken and egg problem again we
were still chasing and trying to fix
this so what do we do we we can't you
know build a one-size-fits-all solution
every every organization is different
every company has different needs and
that's totally understandable and and
the hardshell perimeter model or you
know I think it's also called the
eggshell model it doesn't doesn't work
very well anymore because we've seen
examples in the past where infiltrators
have been inside the company and that's
that's not gonna work anymore so so we
take micro segmentation at every layer
very seriously and and that's why we we
think about security the
defense-in-depth model also referred to
as the onion model which is why you see
that picture there and to to relate that
onion model to anthos we really think
about anthos in three different layers
of infrastructure we think of them
starting at the bottom of the pyramid
with nodes we all know our VMs we love
our VMs they're awesome
and we've also protected them in
firewalls for an eternity at this point
so we're not gonna talk about firewalls
right and the next level up from nodes
is pods kubernetes pods which is
somewhere in the middle of you know
nodes and services and then finally at
the top we have sto services which is
you know our new service mesh that we're
talking about so so there's the those
are those three levels that we were
imagining again anthos as and and we
want to think about security at each of
these layers to give you a very strong
defense in depth security posture it's
it actually still says that the clusters
are in California Illinois North
Carolina and Texas so so just imagine
the united states them out there so I
want to motivate the example here a
little bit more because we're really
talking about multi cluster now we've
we've done one cluster we're now going
out and deploying multiple clusters all
around this country the globe would have
you and what we want to try to do is
understand what sort of problems we get
into and when we start talking about
security at this scale so imagine a
retail bank I mean this could be retail
anything a retail bank it's running on
anthos what that means is they've
deployed four unique gke on Prem
clusters so they're all independent
standalone gke clusters running
on-premises in the branch and the idea
there is that the bank has realized that
it real-time services for their
customers is super important so they've
taken the step and they've adopted GK on
Prem that's great and they've deployed
four
for now they've gone to California
Illinois North Carolina and Texas so
this is great but now you're already
asking the question how do I keep these
things in sync right because you can
change one thing on one cluster and then
suddenly all of your other clusters are
out of sync right that's not all once
that starts happening you have fleet
fragmentation because your apps start
you know diverging inversions and the
worst part of it all is that leads to
your secure all your development teams
adopting a different workflow for
production and deployment and that is a
security nightmare for every one of us
so we want to prevent that okay just to
motivate the example a bit more I want
to show you what's what they're running
inside it's a simplistic example we've
obviously curated the details for you to
get the most out of the session it could
be much more complex a set up but
imagine the each cluster is running
three services primarily account summary
products and PII database the idea here
is that a teller could you know could
come to the homepage and look up a
customer's account summary by you know
making the request and the account
summary can get access to PII database
the product service or any other service
for that matter should not be able to
get to the PII database under any
circumstances so that's our sort of you
know set up for this this problem and
we're gonna work through this
step-by-step to see how we can use all
the layers of anthos namely kubernetes
and sto to protect this and get the
posture that we want okay
never policy how many of you have heard
of number policy kubernetes and Foss
okay okay okay maybe like a fourth maybe
a third of the room maybe I don't know
okay so that's that's good why why do we
need it okay so we have pods that I told
you about earlier pods when you deploy
kubernetes pods today in your system by
default they can talk to anything right
this can be a good thing and a bad thing
depending on how you're looking at it
from a developer's point point of view
it's awesome because you can get access
to whatever you want from a security
person's point of view it's not cool
because you need to be able to lock it
down and make sure that the surface area
is protected so so keeping that in mind
we have this feature in kubernetes it's
it's OSS we fully support it in GCP and
GK so you can think of it as a as a
firewall for your pods of sorts what it
does is it cuts down any sort of
unrestricted traffic out of the system
so your pods can never go out and do
stuff that you don't want them to do so
that's the idea behind this you can
express rich ingress and egress rules
using this policy on this API you can
actually write IP addresses and cider
blocks if you choose to
I recommend how you can do that though
you can use kubernetes labels and you
can also use kubernetes namespaces so
that's awesome because it's a
first-class citizen and finally if
you're already using namespaces and
kubernetes to support your workloads and
and you know keep them grouped and
separated in some sense logically you
can use kubernetes network policy really
easily as it is a namespace property so
it applies to all your pods within the
namespace instantly so that's really
really cool all right so let's bring it
back to the example that we looked at
earlier we had our account summary
service we had products and our mission
was we don't want any other service
except for account summary service to be
able to talk to the PII database so here
I've set up a simple policy in every
policy object it's missing a few details
but the key things are highlighted what
we're trying to do here is we're trying
to select the PII database pods right so
emphasize the factor that we're
selecting pods here we're not talking
about services just yet we're talking
about pods we're still in the middle of
VMs and services so we're at pods so
we're selecting our PII database pods
and what we're doing is when the moment
we implement a number of policy
selecting the PII database pods all the
traffic is cut from PII database so the
PII data based pods cannot go out to the
internet cannot go out to other services
or other pods other pods can't come to
the PII database it's a purely whitelist
model so a whitelist model means you
have to explicitly now tell the system
what traffic is allowed to come to pee a
database or go from the PII data base so
the words we use for that is ingress and
egress which I'm sure all of you are
very familiar with so just to sort of
summarize that that comment the moment
you create a number of policy object and
you select all the PII database pods all
those all the communication all network
traffic is cut off from them immediately
now you go take the next step and you
say okay I want to allow ingress from
account summary to PII database so you
say ok well I'm gonna select all the
pods that are running account summary
service and I'm gonna let them talk to
PII data base that's great and that
actually solves our problem here
so I've we've talked about ingress but
we left out the egress part just yet so
you can actually either mention the
egress keyword here or leave it out
completely because as I mentioned
earlier by putting it under a policy
you've already cut traffic from it
entirely so it's a whitelist model if
you do not enable explicitly any egress
sources no traffic is leaving your pods
and you can be sure of that all right
we're moving a level up now so we've
talked about our pods that's great
we've secured them and at a lower level
of the infrastructure that's fantastic
we've cut our surface area we know for
sure that some of the IP traffic we
don't want to reach the pods is not
reaching them that's awesome but now we
have to start thinking about our our
services so who here has already heard
about HDS security policy almost the
same fraction of people not the same
people same fraction of people okay so
what we were gonna try to do is just
actually how many of you've heard of
Steel and understand what it's do is
almost okay good good I'll try to like
just I came up with a cool analogy I
think it's cool I'm biased I'm sorry
I'll give you a cool analogy to how I
understand this do so it's imagine
you're your host at a birthday party
with lots of children running around
these children are micro-services and
and you're trying to protect them from
getting hurt right so if you can
actually like you know strap balloons
and stuff across everybody that would be
great but you can't there's too many
kids running around you can
do that so so you can imagine sto coming
in and helping you there and saying ok
I'm gonna let you control these micro
services because luckily micro services
are easier to control then kids are at a
birthday party but yeah that's my
analogy you feel free to use it if you
want to but yeah that's where we're
going with this so to control all your
your you know I steal micro services you
need to put security policies in place
what do we have here so we first of all
start with strongly authenticating all
our services as well as our users so
it's do by itself issues strong
identities and a strong non mutable
identities to each service that's
running inside your your mesh so this is
great because we'll talk about the next
point here in a moment but this is great
because it's non mutable identity so you
don't have to lift a finger for this sto
does it for you right off the bat and
users are also authenticated by the
system but the identity is not issued
what we'll touch on that in more detail
later so let's keep going ok encryption
for everyone so because we've
authenticated everybody in the system
including users including services we
can use that identity to encrypt and
establish an EM TLS channel between all
your traffic within the mesh so you can
get services service encryption for
basically free without having to change
anything and context based authorization
so we've done authentication we've done
encryption but we also want to do
authorization because we want to make
sure that only certain parts of the
system are accessible and certain parts
are completely off access because really
access is really a non-binary thing it's
it's more of a you know spectrum some
people have access to certain things
some people have access to other things
so we're gonna look at how to do partial
access as well ok going back to our
example so let's start with
authentication in this case I've set up
a simple example again these are these
are some of the most common examples I
see when people have questions so
there's more details if you you know if
you keep reading more and more more
you'll be getting very excited about
security as I do but here I've taken a
simple example of user authentication
what's happening here is we're using a
policy object it's do policy object here
and we're selecting the PII database
service in this case not pods we moved
up a layer so this is the sto the PII
database is the sto service that we're
targeting here and we're selecting it
under this policy object and we're
saying only let users who have Josh
tokens issued by Acme comm access this
service so Jacque tokens if people are
familiar they're a common OID C protocol
implementation and a lot of times it
could be Active Directory or you know
octa or any other provider like that but
st uses dot for the time being and in
this case you could provide a signed
token from Acme comm and the system will
let you through which is great because
if it's coming from fake me calm it
won't be allowed access okay encryption
in transit so we've done identity that's
awesome how do we take it from there to
giving you encryption well you don't
have to do anything it the system does
it for you how does it do it we have a
little thing called envoy a sidecar
proxy that's part of this sto bundle the
sto bundle installs the Envoy proxy in
front of all of your micro services and
every time you have a service that wants
to talk to another service if you enable
this policy so in this case what we're
doing is the PII database service is
being targeted by this policy and it's
saying all my peers should use MPLS
while talking to me and the the curly
brackets they're not specifying a
service means all all services so what
what this does is it it forces all of
the people or all of the services that
are trying to talk to Pai database
ensure that they have em TLS enabled or
encryption enabled the one thing I
didn't show here is it's called the
destination rule arrival and briefly
touch upon that in his demo to show you
how account summary can start talking to
P i database using M TLS by setting a
destination rule after this policy
authorization so we've done two things
so far we've prevented untrusted access
to the system and we've prevented
man-in-the-middle attacks well that's
not sufficient as I mentioned earlier a
lot of times your
have partial access to the system they
don't have full access to the system so
how do you go about doing that so in our
in our little example here I want to
allow tellers to only be able to read
the PII database but not write anything
to the database so what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna set up a service
role called PII viewer and what that
role is doing here is is it's granting
get permissions to the PII database so
the get would be the HTTP equivalent of
read and if when you associate that
service role with the service role
binding and in that service role binding
what you're specifying is that the
access has to come from accounts summary
and it has to come from a group called
tellers so that group is actually coming
from the jot token that I mentioned
earlier these are details you can you
know read about more if you wanted to or
I'm happy to answer questions afterwards
if you have any but the idea here is
that you're very clearly specifying in
your authorization policy what is
allowed to access your PI database
service and what is not and only the
tellers group can do a read here so
we've talked about several policies
already and I kind of want to show a
picture of how they all fit together and
how they work in in in harmony you know
so to speak this is the path we really
want we want a user at Acme calm or
teller at Acme comm to be able to access
account summary and be able to get to
PII database so we lock down the the
access from PII database to the internet
and we lock down any other service any
other pods from being able to reach to
the PII database so we we cut that out
first right that was our first number of
policy objects that we created it locked
down access from products to PII
database we also cut out access to
Internet so PII database if it had any
faulty code or anything inadvertently
tried to go to the Internet that's all
cut out also then we went into
authentication we cut out access from
fake me calm and any other websites that
might be issuing tokens and trying to
access your system we enabled encryption
so that account summary and Thea
database are always talking on
the channel so that none of your man in
the middle attacks can actually steal
data from you we we also cuts down the
HTTP POST request from user or doc be
calm what we're trying to do here is
very clearly you know draw a line
between what's allowed from the tellers
group and what's not and if the the
teller got really like clever here and
tried to bypass the account summary that
would also be rejected so the only path
left in the system is this one and
that's what we just implemented with
three simple policies so I just wanted
like you know just show you like the
power of this sort of fly-by-wire
security system where you're you're
doing everything based on policy
you're not configuring firewalls anymore
you're not configuring manual switches
anymore this is this is moving above a
layer and it's giving you a real
fly-by-wire experience because you can
do all this by setting a few policies
and all of the fabric will change
according to your requirements to give
you as high microsegmentation as you
could possibly imagine just to quickly
distinguish between the two policies
that we've talked about we've talked
about kubernetes never a policy we've
talked about SD a security policy you
might be asking why we have to use both
the real answer is where they're both
good at really they're really good at
different things so kubernetes number
policy is really good at cutting down
your attack surface area while it's new
security policy gives you fine-grained
access control at the service level so
you need the umbrella and the raincoat
to protect you from the rain and now we
have our demo please welcome ray hi
everyone i'm ray calling I'm a software
engineer and I work on anthos config
management and so today what we want to
do is take you through a demo which is
going to show a lot of the concepts that
Gobin just talked about in his
presentation and if you've installed sto
it comes with an example application
which looks a lot like the bank example
that Gobin just said or talked about so
here we have a ratings app you could
think of this as the PII database you
have a reviews
system which you could think of as like
the account summary and then you have
basically a product page at the front
and these three things then get requests
and then they're allowed to talk to
these different backends now I'm also
going to be demoing anthos config
management as a way to deploy the book
the book info app and show it on two
different clusters at the same time so
the idea here is if you're running in
two different availability zones or in
two different regions you can deploy
this app using one set of edits into a
git repo and then those will propagate
off to each of the clusters and if you
wanted to do a progressive rollout you
could insert a cloud build pipeline
which basically each cluster gets its
configure than ten minutes or an hour
later it could go ahead and and and get
the other one you could stick a canary
analysis a service or something else in
between so with that said let's go
through and kind of show you the setup
here so we have two clusters one is in
US central one and one is in u.s. East
four and these are just really simple
simple clusters you'll see currently on
the URL here that there's nothing there
and on here there's nothing there and
when we switch over I'll go over here so
what we'll see here is we have in this
window is looking at all the pods
for cluster one here we're looking at
all the pods for cluster two and here
we're looking at cluster twos service
role so these are policies and this here
is my git repo local git repo where I'm
going to be making my changes and
pushing them now this gets sent up to
github and github is right here which
you can see also if i refresh it has
nothing in it right it is just a blank
thing with system which is the default
way so these clusters i've installed the
sto operator and i've i installed the
anthos config management operator and
then i configured the anthos config
operator as as such alright so what we
can see here is when we look at cluster
one you'll see that it's just a regular
ya mole to configure config management
and we give it a cluster name so
amazingly in crew
there's no cluster identity built-in so
we actually give each cluster a name so
we can refer to it for purposes of being
able to target policies at a given
cluster we then tell it where to go so
I'm telling it hey go to github and go
to this this root here and then I could
tell it which which branch so I'm saying
go to master and if you wanted to go to
canary you could go to canary you could
end up creating a branch and using the
git merge functionality to push things
along at this point I'm telling you to
use SSH we support SSH and get cookies
and I'm saying hey use this root as the
policy directory and that means you can
use one repo and have different
environments in one repo if you want or
you could have different repos it's up
to up to each person or environment so
anyways I've installed that on two
clusters and so let's go at this point
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to deploy
the book info app but I'm gonna deploy
it in securely so everything is plain
text there's no security rules and
everything can talk to each other all
right and so what you'll see here is
I've created a new namespaces directory
I've created a book info namespace I've
created the namespace Yambol which is
the same one you would cube cuddle apply
I've created a book info which has a set
of services and a set of deployments
which map to the four different services
that are said and a book info gateway
which exposes it to the outside of my my
cluster so at this point I'm gonna go
ahead and add this initial deployment
and then I'm gonna get push okay so that
gets pushed up and then we can do what
we'll notice on the right hand side is
these pods will start start creating and
and there we go so on clustered who
picked it up and it's going ahead and
deploying the app as we review this and
then we have that on cluster one so
what's going on in the background is
there's an agent running on each cluster
that's looking at that github repo I
showed you earlier and it senses that
there's a new change in there and it
goes ahead and pulls down that stuff and
cube huddle applies everything in that
in that repo automatically
okay so when we go into namespaces right
you'll see here that these are just
everyday standard standard files right
so here we have a service here we have a
deployment right service deployment you
know
ports etc ok cool so with that said what
we should see here is our bookstore app
and we have the details which is one
service and we have the product page
which is this overall page and we have
the book reviews which is comprised of
two services one is the review and one
is the rating and you'll notice that in
the book info example there's three
versions of the ratings and if i refresh
this you'll see that we are doing
round-robin and that works not as fast
here and these should change over time
as in this is a different version and
they're changing so this is showing us
that it's geo routing and what you can
do with this Dao which is also cool
which which we didn't or gobind in cover
is there's also this idea of routing and
so you can run multiple versions at the
same time and you can do traffic shaping
and traffic urban traffic spreading and
rollout 5% 10% etc to new versions to
make sure that things are happening in
addition to all the security benefits ok
so now that we have this deployed it's
insecure what we want to do is we want
to layer encryption on top of this so we
want all the pieces here instead of
being plain text we want them to
actually have the nice little barrel of
encryption around them so let's figure
out how to do that so I go back here and
what you'll notice is in the current
images so I've gotten all the pods that
are there these are the images that are
running which is just the book info
software ok as we stated with earlier is
that isseo has a sidecar proxy that runs
as a container and that gets injected
when you run your pods and that's where
the proxy happens and then what happened
then the the way that the docker
networking stack gets set up is we only
allow those pods to talk to the proxy
and nothing else
so now all ingress and egress must
transit through the proxy and that gives
sto that gives you the security
guarantees
that sto gives you so let's do that so
an able MT LS on each you'll see here
that I ended up with some extra files
which I'll talk about in a minute here
and let's go ahead and add some okay so
we're adding some MT LS we're pushing
that up let's go look what actually
happened here okay when we go to book
info and we look now at the namespace
you'll see here that we have this
comment called sto injection enabled
right and I'll do this because syntax
highlighting is fun all right so we have
SEO injection enabled and what this says
is any time you create a pod go ahead
and automatically add the SEO sidecar to
that to that pod the container the
estilo proxy container to that pod and
wire it up so that they only could talk
through the proxy cool now now that we
have that enabled oh and we'll talk
about destination rules to which are fun
so with destination rules what we're
saying here is hey if I'm gonna go ahead
and you know talk to the product page
I'm gonna use sto mutual and that means
that when I talk outbound to egress I'm
gonna use and I want to talk to the
review service I'm going to use em TLS
and this is set for all the things
ratings reviews details and this says
hey on those arrows go ahead and encrypt
those with M TLS when I talk and then
the other thing that we did here is at
the cluster level when I go to cluster I
have a mesh policy now now within CSP
config management when you have put
things in the cluster directory that
gets pushed to the root level of each
cluster that's being managed and so now
cluster 1 and cluster 2 both have this
mesh policy that says the following
it sets a default policy and it says M
TLS so it says any pods in any namespace
must use M TLS to be talked to and so
that that helps you as an administrator
guarantee that you're using M TLS okay
now what we're going to notice here is
because we've
change the makeup of the pods we
actually doesn't that doesn't reconcile
automatically and when we show the
current images we still have this do
look info so we need to restart the pots
I'm so I'm going to show you a feature
of anthos config management which let
which is called which my coworker
facetiously named insistent
reconciliation and that means that
whatever the state that's in the repo we
guarantee that we make the cluster that
state so if I destroy the deployments
which I defined in the repo the anthos
config management will automatically
recreate them so I'm gonna go ahead and
kill those deployments and you'll see
here that here they've gotten all
deleted you'll see that you'll have a
bunch terminating and now you have a
bunch initializing at the same time and
so that happened because the the Anthes
config management wants the cluster to
be in the state of the repo so we can
have that guarantee so at this point
what I'm gonna do is show the current
images and what you're going to see here
is three of them have now picked up the
sto proxy and then you have the three
that are terminating which will go away
soon so now we have sto proxy sitting in
front of our existing pods we have told
the system to use em TLS we have
encryption across all setups so at this
point what I should see is when i
refresh this assuming everything is
speedy is the book app should be working
as is which it looks like it is sweet
except now everything is talking
encrypted between all these different
points ok cool
so next step now that we got encryption
what we want is the ability to lock
things down right and we want to say you
know what it's great that you have
encryption it's great that you have
authenticate our authentication but now
let's put some authorization into the
mix and we're gonna start by just
turning on authorization but setting no
policy so it's deny by default so we're
gonna go ahead and enable service are
back and you'll see here that we got a
cluster are back so let's go ahead and
push that
and iMac and then get bush so when that
goes ahead and push let's go look at
that cluster our back policy and see
what it says so here we go we have a
cluster are back config we have applied
at the at the you know name default so
it's the root one for all the whole
cluster and it's saying for this
namespace right
please enforce and enforces deny by
default which means you have to
explicitly list the are back service
binding in order for things to talk to
services and so now this forces all of
the provide application writers on your
clusters to explicitly detail their
dependencies so in this case we're gonna
want to be able to each one of these
things is going to require a rule so
product page could talk to reviews and
product page could talk to details and D
and reviews can talk to ratings okay so
we push that we're saying it's enforced
what I would expect to happen here now
that we have that is the app should
break and it has and you'll see here
that on both clusters I get our back
access tonight I tried to hit the
product page the product when I hit
there there was it said there's our back
there's no are back authorization
allowing my user to get the product page
so it's a go away great so with that
said let's go ahead and add a partial
rule to show how you can add
authorization on a piecemeal basis
okay so we're gonna do adding a our back
policy so you'll see here that we got a
namespace policy file we're gonna go
ahead and add that partial policy and
get push okay so while that's going on
and again all this is happening through
those config management I'm not running
cube cuddle at all
it's all happening behind the scenes
when I go into the namespace there's
extra credit if people can realize that
a couple things here about the security
aspects of these policies and of the
page I'll see if anyone identified them
at the end and and go from there so when
we look at this namespace policy you'll
see here that I have a service viewer
role and what I'm saying is is that all
services so we're basically matching any
any URL right any method get' and I'm
saying allow these apps product page and
details to talk to each other okay so
I'm allowing the product page to talk
and I'm allowing people to talk to the
product page but the details are being
able to be talk to you by the product
page all right but notice what's missing
here ratings and reviews and then down
here I have a role binding which bit
binds both the sto system namespace so
it can get telemetry right and the book
info namespace which says hey things
running a book info are allowed to be
given this this role as long as they
have the constraints of the destination
labels being product and details okay so
what we should notice now is a partially
working app on both clusters and that's
what we have we have the details we have
the product page but we have no product
reviews there's been an error because
it's got an our back denied which will
return as a 403 okay cool so that's
great we've been able to partially do
that let's add the full and by the way
just to show you that this is all real
we have all these things within the git
repo github repo okay so we're going to
go ahead and have the full service our
back policy
and from there we're getting okay so
that's pushing you notice how here we
have a service viewer policy I just got
pushed earlier with that said let's look
at our namespace policy now you'll see
that we've added reviews and we've added
ratings okay so at this point everything
is allowed to talk right we have we've
enabled that and so let's write that out
cool that's been pushed earlier we
should notice that the app starts
working and there it is right and doing
the right thing through that so great
we've just now gone back through we've
started with an empty cluster just with
sto and just with anthos config
management we deployed the book info app
in securely we layered on MT LS we added
cluster our back policy saying deny by
default we layered on a couple of
different policies to have the app be
able to talk to each other and at this
point we have a fully kind of enabled
our back Sto application that has been
working from the beginning from the
insecure state to adding and layering on
sto and I never changed a line of code
in the SEO book info app and to finish
it off I'm gonna go ahead and remove
everything so that takes my repo back to
normal and then I'm just gonna push this
so get a - a git commit dash M kill at
all and then I'm gonna push that okay
and as a final thing if I actually go up
here what we will see is all of these
things will go to terminating they will
remove the clusters because if they're
not in an throws config management we go
ahead and we'll take them out of the
clusters that's one of the things that
we guarantee again we want the state of
the clusters to match the state of the
repo and so with that that's kind of our
demo of anthos config management and of
ISTE oh thank you everyone
can we switch back to the slides please
all right thanks ray thanks for that
awesome demo so originally ad I said
that you know your workflow might change
that was a that's actually what I was
referring to instead of using cue cuddle
you'll start doing get push everywhere
it's gonna be awesome so thank you for
that so we've we've put all of this
together you know we we actually looked
at this diagram here go back yeah so so
ray helped us see some of the core
pieces of this this picture just from
the power of git push which is great you
can do this across all your clusters
this is it'll give you a lot of peace of
mind because you'll be sure that all
your clusters are running exactly the
posture that you want so going forward
so we've talked about how to deploy
these policies how to construct these
policies but there's one more piece of
the puzzle which is how do you keep an
eye on everything and and that's where
GCP console and anthos really brings it
all together for you as an ecosystem you
can you can connect all your gke
clusters or ant those clusters to GCP
console and you can see them all in one
place
you can see all the details related to
that any of your clusters wherever
they're running again it could be on
Prem it could be GCP could be AWS you
always to do is log into those clusters
from GCPs console and you'll be able to
see all the relevant details of the
control plane in your DCP console and as
well that goes for stackdriver so Streck
drivers are our logging tool you can use
a stack driver to pull all the logs from
your different clusters that you're
running across the planet and bring them
for the stack driver for analysis you
could push them through to bigquery if
you wanted to you could also use other
tools if you're familiar with you know
if you prefer Prometheus and Griffin
offer for you know graphing them that's
also great and if you wanted to use
plunk or elastic all of that is
supported as well all right well we're
close to the finish line
so really the three things that we
started with here were one we we wanted
to give you a defense-in-depth
experience using this fly-by-wire
concept of policy-based security that's
really what
and this is all about we talked in depth
about very high resolution security that
you can get using sto and and kubernetes
policies and finally we looked at Antos
config management as a as a as a way to
do get offs and and put the or you know
infrastructure as code really is a
workflow for CI CD pipelines so you can
actually take all of your security
posture and replicate it across as many
clusters as you'd like in an instant
well one final call out to all the other
security things that you have to think
about as a network administrator so that
we've been you know talking about anthos
clusters in in in a very high detail but
outside the cluster there's a lot of
other stuff happening too so you have to
think about things like you know your
other infrastructure pieces to think
about DDoS attacks you to think about
exfiltration to think about secure
access to your nodes so I highly
encourage you to look at all the other
tools that GCP provides for you to
ensure that you have a security posture
that is comfortable for you there's some
related sessions I know this is towards
the end of the the conference but
they'll all be available at on YouTube
so please check them out they're highly
related to the content that we've
covered and the rest of them are offered
here below at that link with that I'd
like to thank you for your time I
appreciate you guys staying back you
know on a Thursday afternoon thank you
for coming here and thank you for
attending next
[Music]